did you Sam have you heard the story
about how the Mormon church has a
hundred billion dollar hedge fund yeah
that kills my eye yeah that was that
that's old right that's from 2019 or
2019. exactly
um and Ben you're Ben you are uh I don't
know how to explain it you are Mormon
you are a member of this great business
you are a patron of the business
um that we described uh first so far Ben
have I offended you not yet okay great
let's fix that
keep going so you're saying this chance
[Music]
all right we're live uh dude you're
wearing the brightest sweatshirt it's
like bothering me almost I'm here and
I'm ready to to shine bright like a
diamond Rihanna Style
oh diamonds actually this kind of looks
like Rihanna's halftime outfit a little
bit if I just had the belly bump it
would I'd be there some would say I do
I I wouldn't say that Subway but I
wouldn't I had to take the shot before
you did there no I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna you're not chubby anymore you're
uh you're strong so you got your [__]
right bro we I've got a couple things to
cover that are pretty good I think you
do too yeah I'm look I'm locked and
loaded all right do it what do you got
it's amazing what not running another
business will do to you so much so much
time to um to work on this podcast okay
I want to tell you about
what I think might be the greatest
business of all time
okay the greatest business ever I think
this is the greatest business ever
and I'm going to convince you of that
uh let me let's just walk through before
I even tell you which one it is let me
walk through the criteria for a business
like this okay so
if we were going to describe the
greatest business of all time what would
be some of the you gotta have attributes
what would be some of the attributes so
the iPhone LTV
high high LTV so you want a customer
around for a long time that pays you for
a long time okay great uh what about
like let's say I told you there's a high
LTV business but it's only been around
for 18 months well you'd be like I don't
know not a long operating track track
record or history here so you want
longevity right you want longevity years
what if I told you this business maybe
been around for a thousand plus years
without obviously you'd be interested in
okay let's get to something are you
gonna tell me that there's tax tax
advantages too
this business doesn't pay any taxes okay
I love this no taxes how does that sound
I like that I like it even better if the
government would subsidize it that's a
thing but yeah that sounds great to me
yeah I like that kind of mom had to come
back out for this one okay
um cost structure what if I told you you
basically don't employ anybody
volunteers do all the work and there are
franchisees essentially that pop up to
sell your product and just pay you a
royalty wouldn't that be quite nice I'd
say hallelujah I love that what if I
told you you know you might say well
what's the balance sheet look like okay
you've told me the p l is fantastic but
what about the balance sheet well
what if I told you that these types of
companies have uh this this this product
this business has
not just billions of dollars but but
often tens of billions or hundreds of
billions of dollars in assets on the
balance sheet with no liabilities
wouldn't that be something you'd be
interested in I would be very interested
in this yes I pray to God and I would
thank that God that that gave me this
idea you're a product guy you love
product it's all about products hair
products any product any type of product
you love it this is a product beloved by
millions has insane product Market fit
people use it daily weekly didn't even
need an app they could just use it in
their head it's that good even if
there's evidence
that it it's a bad product if if
somebody said hey there is no proof that
this product works
they might they would not care they
would not care they would not hear a
word of that they would like it even
more baby
in fact in fact it drives them together
uh what if I told you this product
spreads By Word of Mouth what if I told
you that some people would not only
teach their kids but they would leave
their house go to other people's houses
knock on their door and tell them about
this product that's how much they
believe in this product
you're going to be true core issues
they're morals they're ethics their
Community their self-development what if
I told you that the product is so good
it not just guarantees you a good life
today if you use the product but not but
in your afterlife when you die you might
go to a nice special place where you'll
be happy after you die that's how good
this product is eternal LTV I'm in what
if I told you it touches every part of
your life cycle from when you're a baby
to when you're old and dead how you pay
for your funeral and everything in
between your marriage
um you know give away part of your
salary to this to this company just
because you feel like it and uh it's a
part of everything in between what if I
told you this this company not just sold
this product but also had the number one
best-selling book of all time this
sounds like the Crips and bloods like a
gang but even better your blood in blood
out I love this you love real estate
they also own a [__] ton of real estate
so tons of real estate okay so let's
let's review billions in Revenue tax
free with basically no customer
acquisition cost and super super high
LTV it's a product that solves the core
need spreads via word of mouth and the
people who use it believe it use it
daily day to day week to week month and
they're willing to Die For It
people run this business with volunteers
and franchisees it lasts for a thousand
years has Network effects it sells an
information product there's no
manufacturing even involved it's got the
number one book of all time and the Tam
the market size is every human from
birth to death how would that sound
because religion is the greatest
business of all time and I want to tell
you why I got excited about this but how
was my rant that was good I uh I uh I
knew where you were going because I'm
I'm you know like I'm born and raised
Catholic I I catch there's you're
stepping in I'm all about this you smell
what I'm farting you know you picked up
on that one quick so
to talk about this because there was
this news article that came out
um or like there was like a wave of news
about this recently but actually there
was like a whistleblower thing in 2019
and Ben Wilson you're gonna have to come
on to talk about this did you Sam have
you heard the story about how the Mormon
church has a hundred billion dollar
hedge fund yeah that kills my eye yeah
that was that that's old right that's
from 2019 or 2019. exactly
um and Ben you're Ben you are uh I don't
know how to explain it you are Mormon
you are a member of this great business
you are a patron of the business
um that we described uh first so far Ben
have I offended you not yet okay great
let's fix that
keep going so you're saying this a
chance
um second Ben what uh can you explain
this 100 billion dollar mega church fund
uh or sorry Mormon church fund and uh
what your reaction to it was when this
dude's broke in 2019. yeah I don't know
how deep you want me to get but the the
Church of Jesus Christ popularly known
as the Mormon Church uh tithes it's uh
its members so we all pay 10 of our
income to the church
and but not only that the church also
has a number of businesses associated
with it uh has um
and a lot of this has comes from over
100 years ago when essentially the
Mormon Church Controlled Utah so it spun
off a lot of those uh businesses it
basically doesn't run businesses anymore
but what it did was create basically a
[__] a big hedge fund and because of
its association with the church
that hedge fund does not pay taxes and
has done really well and now is worth as
you pointed out over 100 billion dollars
yeah could the hedge fund be invested in
just public equities as well yes like
can you just do normal wow so basically
here's here's what the here's how the
hedge fund works so uh so it owns 40
billion worth of U.S stocks so companies
like apple Microsoft yeah uh Facebook
things like that they can't own stocks
that are like seizures entertainment or
like a Starbucks they don't they don't
own that because of the caffeine or
whatever so they they they select
something don't they own a Coca-Cola
Microsoft Apple Facebook they have Tesla
they made eight million dollars on the
GameStop squeeze when that was happening
so that was pretty cool
um they also own two percent of all the
land in Florida which is kind of amazing
they
um they basically grew from 40 billion
to 100 billion just from 2019 to today
uh uh for or or sorry
from that was from 20 like 12 to 2019 so
like in a seven year period it kind of
doubled there uh they also invest in
hedge funds they own 100 Million Dollar
Hotel in Maui they outbid Bill Gates for
like 200 million dollars of land in
Washington uh so land stocks hedge funds
um this is what they do and then they've
donated uh 64 million dollars to charity
since 1985 so that's kind of where the
knock on this comes from which was the
the the complaint was basically
um wow that's a lot of money
um it's just like why they're homeless
when you all got this that's like that
and why are we giving 10 of our income
when maybe I actually need that money
right if it's going to this massive
stockpile and then that's not being
redistributed to this and then the
answer was like they called it this is
where there's some all-time Alzheimer
lines I Gotta Give I gotta give credit
to whoever these people are in the
church that are giving these lines out I
mean you to say these are the straight
face is amazing they go it's a rainy day
fund so this 100 billion dollar fund is
a rainy day fund and actually it did
start out like that that was the initial
intent I believe like in the 70s or
something like that when it started it
was like all right for every six dollars
we get we'll put five towards you know
operations and furthering the mission
and we'll put one away for
um for for the rainy day fund but then
maybe it's still a rainy day it's just
their household now has 100 or 200 or
however many hundreds of millions of
people it is instead of
whatever it was but there's not that
many members I think there's Ben how
many members of this like 16 million
members or something like that it's not
that ballpark yep yeah it's not that
many members um they uh overall overall
they uh uh this thing is just sort of
ballooned up and so I think they don't
know exactly how much members contribute
every year some one guy said seven
billion in the whistle blower report
seven billion there's like some
historians who think uh that's too low
it's probably closer to 30 billion gets
contributed in per year so there's a
there's a bunch of like kind of uh
there's a lack of transparency that's
the second complaint
um because not only was this not openly
discussed like that's why a
whistleblower had to come out and say
hey there's this management company
called Ensign Peak and enzyme Peak is
take getting the money from the Mormon
church and deploying it and the enzyme
Peak is now has 100 billion dollars in a
management and they're not being open
about this and they said well we didn't
want people to know how much money is in
there because then they might not feel
like contributing so that was the first
uh first line the second one is like
well how come you did it through these
like 13 shell companies so that nobody
could track you know what you're
investing in and how and you bought this
mall and you bought the stock what's
going on here they said well we we
obscured it because we didn't want our
members to try to copy and sign Peak and
maybe they would mismanage their funds
not having the same info that we have
and so these are just like I just love
the the you know the sort of the
repartee here between between people
that that were running this thing so I
thought this was kind of amazing and it
was just staggering that they've
accumulated this much wealth from a very
small base of uh of people and that's
why I kind of had this realization oh
man religion really is the greatest
business ever invented and um you know
there's five big ones and then they they
sort of dominate in the same with the
same sort of they all share these same
benefits and characteristics you're
Hindi or Hindu is that what are you
nothing I don't I'm not I'm not a
Believer but yeah like most people in
India are Hindu and is there no Central
Hub there's no organization you know
like the Catholics or the Mormons have
like a like a crew you know you don't
got an HQ
I don't think there's I think it's more
decentralized uh than that so I don't
there's no like
there's no like the church like nobody
says that I don't know I don't know if
that means there's not one or what but
there are many many like temples that
are sort of like the Vatican that get
tons of donations and people make the
pilgrimage and uh there's tons of you
know uh shadiness around that too where
like you know we went and you're in line
on this mountain to get to the top to
see this like statue and then it's like
hey 100 bucks cut the lime and it's like
the guy who's taking the the bribe
essentially the cut cut money he's like
a priest and so they don't even like
obscure it's like the guy comes down in
his robe and is just like oh yeah your
family your family come here come here
uh we want to give you a special uh
special treatment you know do you have
some something to donate and then you're
like yes and then he's like cool cool
come on come to the front of the line
and they found like these guys have
gotten raided and they're uh like these
gurus and sort of like uh you know
leaders in of these temples and they
have like
it's like oh open up your master bedroom
and there's just like piles of gold it's
just like yeah yeah just like you know
it's a gold storage facility actually it
always so I went to Catholic School my
whole life so K to eight or no K to 12
and then I went to a real another
religious college and so we used to go
to church three times a week Catholic
mass three times a week it was like
Monday Friday Sunday for since I was
eight until I was 18. and every week
your mom and dad write a check and they
like someone comes around and like
collects it right and I remember hearing
about this like all-powerful God and how
smart he is and it's like you know this
guy's the greatest you know he's just
he's brilliant you know like he created
us and like you know we just came from
his hip and all this stuff and like
we're just magical like this guy's
magical but he's really bad with money
you know he he he needs and he needs
more of it he needs more of it and he's
just he can't get enough of this money
and he's really bad with it and if he
loves you but look if you don't give him
money you're gonna go to hell where you
burn free all eternity forever
but he loves you and he needs [__]
money
that's [__] guy man
it's like the worst Uncle ever yeah he
just needs money he comes scratching his
neck he's like hey [__] yeah oh yeah
look what he got I think anything you
got you know literally just give me
change you gotta change I'll take a
change you gotta check I'll take a check
and now you can even venmo him and I
just remember being at church every
Sunday thinking this guy man he ain't so
good with money but he's all knowing but
he but he can't he doesn't know which
stocks is short because he could not
figure this out he needs more money
um there's also another little side
thing before we get off this religion
tangent uh Ministry brands have you ever
heard of this PE firm yeah yeah yeah are
they the ones who buy software companies
for churches yeah they brought them up
30 30 Church related software businesses
and it does 100 million in ebitda so 100
million essentially a profit before
taxes
um just on this roll-up which is kind of
amazing I mean it's sort of a billion
dollar billion dollar Church roll-up
which is uh Church software rollup which
is pretty awesome all right I have a
story for you well let's stick with
Scandal and uh like a negative stuff
because I got a good one disclaimer
the product of religion genuinely is
great it genuinely helps people I'm also
just saying that the business of of
religion I think is
amazing from a pure business point of
view and also a little sketchy to me but
I don't think the product is amazing and
the Believers you guys are awesome and
Ben you're awesome you're you're super
awesome and I hope we didn't offend you
I I have you didn't offend me still
haven't offended me but I just like
final word on this which is kind of the
Mormon perspective on our 100 billion
dollar hedge fund which is
um the the leaders of the church uh so
like the prophet the apostles their
salaries got leaked
um by some people who were disaffected
members of the church who want to make
them look bad tell me more what you got
you guys want to know what you guys want
to guess what the salaries were
300 000. that's pretty good I would have
guessed 200 uh 200 170 I well I'm I
believe it was 170 000 a year
um and they get like a car which is
usually like a Toyota Highlander and why
a highlighter that's that's like the
specific is that like Pious that's like
that's like I don't know they just own a
bunch of Toyota stuff there's no cup
holders can't put soda can't put soda in
it my dad was one of these people who
who was getting this he was a clergy so
he you know he's a Stanford MBA was
making a bunch of money they asked him
uh would you come work for the church so
he takes you know like a 90 pay cut and
goes and makes this and he had he's
driving around this is my point Toyota
Highlander just like very middle class
and so the point is no one's getting
rich off of this even the people who
manage uh the hedge fund kind of get
paid below Market rates right they
should get paid fine they get paid well
but less than they would make it other
big hedge funds that are doing equally
well that we know of because because
with the Catholic thing it's a little
bit different right the Catholics on the
Catholic side it was like oh this
whatever Bishop took 17 private jet
rides last year and there was like a
bunch of things like that so so maybe in
this case it wasn't or maybe it was more
obscured where the benefits come from
and not just so obviously on payroll
like but but I know that with other
religions that also have a big balance
sheet also have huge revenues and tax
exempt status the perks were sort of
substantial but this is why it seems
like it's a bigger controversy outside
of the Mormon Church than within it a
lot of people like myself or we hear
about it we're like well I wish it was
200 billion you know like it doesn't
bother us the church says doubling down
on it yeah take 20 of my income yeah
dude well not everybody I mean one guy
sue you know one guy famously was suing
them for five minutes he's like I want
all my tithing money back because I was
basically under the impression this was
going to help people uh or like expand
the church did he get it and that's it
lawsuit for five million dollars and uh
I don't know if that's been resolved yet
let me let me tell you another
interesting the controversial story so
we talk about software as a service
we've talked about SAS we talked about a
few other type of as a service products
I want to talk to you about psyops as a
service meaning psychological warfare so
this story I'm basically uh uh my
researcher here he's around here uh on
the on the um
uh eugino he's here on the Riverside so
he might have to pop in if I get
something wrong but I found this article
that blew my mind and was totally
underplayed and I thought not talked
about enough so I'm going to be
recanting a bunch of this story so
nothing here is crazy original but we
found a bunch of articles that we kind
of timed together so basically this
starts in the summer of 2022 and a bunch
of journalists from all different
newspapers kind of teamed up to uh to to
write this story but it basically is a
um they went undercover and they found
this company it's called team it's it's
pronounced uh I actually don't know how
it's pronounced but it's uh j-o-r-e so
maybe Jorge I'm gonna call it team
George like George like George mosf it
all uh but we're gonna call it team
George
um but it's team George and it's this
Israeli company that does psyops as a
service and so what that means is you
can give them one to ten million dollars
and they'll basically hack stuff for you
and this company it's based in Israel
they have employees this isn't like uh
like the guy who runs it has a LinkedIn
this isn't like a a criminal Enterprise
necessarily this is like a legitimate
company and I want to tell you this
crazy story so it starts off they're a
private they call themselves a private
intelligence agency they charge anywhere
from 50 000 to hack someone's phone four
hundred thousand dollars to have their
services on retainer six million dollars
to get involved with a uh uh an election
six million to meddle in an election
is hilarious that that's on the menu
dude and the guy gives like these crazy
stories so the guy's name his name is
talhanan so he's the guy he's like the
CEO the founder and he does this like
crazy stuff and so basically their
three-step part process is to gather
intelligence construct a narrative and
then deploy Maximum Impact all wonderful
phrases and so I'm going to give you an
example so this guy Tao he's the head of
Team George he's in Kenya with these
journalists who he thinks uh work for an
African government who wants to hire
them to do some work and at the seminar
or at the meeting where he's pitching
his Services he shows his phone tal
shows his phone and he's talking to a
person who's supposed to be an African
government uh consultant or something
like that and he goes here look check
this out I just sent your mom a few
messages from your telegram account and
the guy's like why he goes yeah here's
my phone look I'm logged into your
telegram account I hacked you already
and and so they do these crazy things
where they offer these ridiculous
services so they do they have this tool
called a profiler which is Can it can
create all these different fake social
media accounts and so what they'll do is
they'll figure out what uh what story
they want to conch like who they want to
hurt what story they want to construct
and then they use these fake social
media profiles to make it really popular
and they have something like I think it
was like 50 or six or no sorry 39 000 of
these profiles out there and so here's
like a handful of crazy stories so
here's a couple examples so the clean
that uh the team claimed to have a sex
toy delivered via Amazon to the home of
a politician with the aim of giving his
wife the false impression that he was
having an affair thank you my love it
was a wonderful night waiting for you
whenever you come back write a note
Inside the Box the wife received the
package and then uh the team George they
sent a film crew to film this and they
found the politician sleeping in his
office for the next two days and they
found out who the sender was it was this
woman named Shannon and I think she's
one of their fake avatars and they found
out who she was and she's active on
Twitter and on Facebook and has a Gmail
account and WhatsApp account but I don't
believe This Woman's real and her Amazon
card was connected to a digital wallet
so they could like track all this and so
that's like an example of the things
that they do another thing
that they do is uh to prove uh the
journalists to prove how powerful these
guys are do you know who Emmanuel the
Emu is do you know who that is have you
heard of that person no who's right so
there's this tick tocker this lady who's
got a tick tock and she's wonderful I
followed her forever and she has uh an
emu you know what an emu is like an
ostrich looking thing yeah like a pet
emu that went viral on Tick Tock and she
talks to the Emu and his name's Emmanuel
well the journalist asked team George to
make it go viral that Emmanuel was dead
and so overnight they did that by the
way started really weird requests by the
journalists what the hell were they I
don't know it's just weird they're weird
strange Choice makes zero sense and it
got to the point was where this woman
who owns Emmanuel the Emu who I follow I
love her that's why I found this article
so I saw the story where they're talking
about Emmanuel the Emu I've Loved
Emmanuel I know all about him I own a
manual the Emu t-shirt and the uh for
real and they um uh like she tweeted
today I saw online that R.I.P Emmanuel
the Emu was trending on Twitter so I
just want to let you know I had I ran
outside to check what was going on he's
totally fine I have no idea why this
happened right this company they like
create all these crazy stories well
they'll be like uh hey you know uh one
one company will be like hey the CEO of
this billion dollar company we need a
fro we need something bad to happen to
them uh find some dirt in their past and
what they'll do is they'll hack into a
person's Gmail or Google Google Drive
using that they'll find passwords to all
these other things and they'll create
these crazy stories then they'll use
their network of 20 or 30 or 50 000 fake
social media profiles to share uh all
this stuff and then they'll also bribe
some uh journalists or create fake blogs
where they'll write these stories and
then the avatars or social media
profiles share that stuff crazy
fascinating and I read this article and
it blew my mind it absolutely blew my
mind yeah this is really really wild and
the you know psyops I thought was like
when you use like the social media thing
or articles to influence somebody's uh
beliefs not just like but like hacking
their phone is sort of different
um so so it's interesting that they do
both
um I have a couple quick reactions
number one prices seem really low
um I feel like they can seem low yeah
team George triple your prices this is
this is a small voice stuff for what you
what your the value you're providing I
mean it's only six million dollars to
meddle in an election that's it like uh
you know I'm thinking shit's bigger than
that come on what's going on here so so
I don't really understand their pricing
50 000 to hack it to a phone you know
how much chaos you can cause by hacking
to someone's phone that seems wild so I
think that's crazy uh good find uh that
this business exists that's my second
reaction and my third is
this kind of lines up I think I've I
feel like this is a thing on social
media that people that you sound like a
conspiracy theorist if you bring it up
but it's clearly gonna have it clearly
happens and it makes total sense that
this would happen I also know that this
happens in the like
non-election you know this is basically
also done for influencer marketing right
like what uh like we've talked about
um
my buddy Steve Bartlett and how he used
to own a huge number of Twitter pages
and he would own pages that had nothing
to do with anything you'd be like you
know
um Hermione's favorite books it's like
some Harry Potter fan page and they
would have like freshman problems they
would on that page and like things I
overheard in Manchester they would they
would own that so they own a bunch of
things that if you were like a
14 to 21 year old in the United Kingdom
you followed probably you know four to
eight of their accounts and so what they
would do was when we wanted our app to
go to to grow and to our goal was to um
to go get a bunch of downloads for cheap
we worked with him and I was like all
right Steve what can we do to grow this
thing he's like well we can use my
network and I was like great so just say
uh
um you know hey this is a great app uh
download it uh you know blah blah blah
here's the link and he's like he just
looked at me like okay you know get out
of here get out of the room dad like you
know you don't understand and he was
like yeah we're not gonna say this is a
great app because nobody cares and that
looks like an ad we're gonna say like my
mom's reaction when she sees me checking
bibo for the 43rd time that day and then
it's a mom slapping a kid I was like oh
well I don't think that's a good image
for a new app and he's like no he's like
do that and then be like
um
you know when I you know when I
um you know my notifications blown up
because of this annoying effing Vivo app
and it shows 47 notifications like but
you're calling it annoying that seems
bad right Steve he's like no when
somebody sees that there's an app that
has 47 notifications they want to know
what it is and that you're complaining
about it makes it look like not an ad
and I was like but then where are you
gonna find the link he's like I put the
name bibo in the thing they'll go yeah
they're gonna look search for it and
he's like then they'll search for it and
then they'll find it and then they'll
share it because they saw seven he's
like when you hear five people talk
about something on social media the same
thing in a day that you hadn't heard
about it feels like everybody's talking
about it and that was his core Insight
we called this the Thunderclap and we
did it and we ranked number one in the
end
Thunderclap is like the name of going
getting popular
yeah that's what he called whenever when
all the accounts start talking about it
at the same time that's great on the
same day yeah Thunderclap who made that
up you make that up well I used to say
that when like you know it's you know if
your thighs get together or something
like that oh it's a Thunderclap and I
just decided to reuse it for a better
purpose now so when your thighs get
together just messing around yeah we
made that up but I think it is actually
a social media term I remember looking
it up because I was like oh this is
genius what do you call it when all the
accounts on the same day just flip on
and start organically talking about
something uh like what is that and it's
some other person had made that up so I
stole that name off them
um but basically that's what that's what
these guys were able to do and he used
to and we've talked about this before so
I'm repeating a story here but like he
gave a talk once on stage and goes watch
this this is you know whatever I've made
up a name like Freddy DB Freddie DB yeah
he puts him on he puts a slide on the
screen of him wearing like an you know a
Manchester United uniform and he goes
Freddie DB just signed with Manchester
United for 72 million dollars uh one of
the craziest contracts for a prospect
who's only 17 years old
um oh but the thing is Freddie DB
doesn't exist and he never signed a
contract but watch this we're gonna make
this go viral just by the end of my talk
this will be trending on Twitter and oh
my God he like nodded to like you know
one of the like 19 year olds that worked
for him off stage he goes they like like
launch the missile and that's exactly
what they did by the end of the thing it
was trending real like you know sort of
like ESPN type news sites started
picking it up like Freddie DB signs for
72 million because like they're all
trying to find information on it but
they just publish first because they
don't want to be late to the news and it
just showed how much influence you could
have and so this happens I think from a
commercial for like you know just in the
business World Plus in this case for
like you know political power [__]
that's wild what a badass presentation I
mean that's like that's a really good
presentation I mean that's like a
swagger like the Swagger knob is broken
it's just stuck on 12. there's nothing
you could do we've tried to take them
into the shop the hustle we now are read
by about three million people a day so
we're not a big deal
um and we're definitely not like
influential enough that one of these
companies would be like let's get that
company to influence the masses but and
like same with this podcast like we're
not we're not a big enough deal or we're
a Target where someone's gonna or at
least I don't think so or someone's back
I'm gonna trick them into saying this
because then they're gonna like actually
have uh influence over the outcome of
whatever we want we'll make your
analytics guy say what happened today
but that's it nothing's going crazy
yeah like it might be a little bit of
note on like your spread your
spreadsheet for that day but that's the
at best that's it and uh but like I
would see a little bit of this like fake
news stuff because I would do little
tests where I would create like you know
uh so my parents do this all the time
they'll look up a celebrity and they'll
say oh Nick Cannon only worth eight
million dollars that's not it's not even
a big deal and I'm like you guys like
and like they won't even like click the
article sometimes they just see like the
paragraph text and and I'm like or
they'll be like uh their day today or
this past weekend I was with my
father-in-law and he's like oh look if
you Google it it says the worst way to
sleep is on your belly and it's like
because we're talking about cancer yeah
yeah I'm like you guys realize like like
anyone can write these articles and I
can make them show up and so I used to
write these articles about net worth so
like Ross Albright the Silk Road guy I
would write an article about his net
worth I would just [__] make it up
I'd have no idea what it is I would just
make it up and I would track my
analytics and people would start linking
to it and I would start getting traffic
and that happened a lot of times or
there'd be times where I made errors in
articles and I noticed I would see that
same air in on a few other people's
websites and you start seeing wow this
is how it starts like these little
things that's how it starts and so this
whole fake news conspiracy
it's one of the few things where I'm
like no there's actually truth to that
like and I have very small examples of
that but if you're like a much bigger
deal you can find lots of bigger
examples of that it's actually this
whole fake news thing is it is 100 real
and so this story is definitely proof of
that
dude as soon as you see how the sausage
is made in any industry it just really
ruins it for you
um I remember when we were doing our
restaurant startup we were like dude we
don't know anything about restaurants
like how does a restaurant even work
like this is like what are we doing and
we had learned a little bit about sushi
because we did a sushi restaurant but I
was like uh Dan who's my our business
partner was like raw fish seems like the
best the best platform to learn by the
way yeah yeah yeah exactly
my favorite sport Russian Roulette yeah
so we were like Dan go work at Noodles
and Company and go learn their like
processed stuff and he's like all right
so you did this Duke graduate goes
applies for a job at Noodles and Company
they're like wow son you you interned at
Goldman Sachs and now you're here
it's always been a dream to be on the
back line and they they whatever and so
he used to bring home Noodles and
Company every night and we were like
dude what's uh so he's like he's like
bro the the way they make this the way
that he's like the amount of salt in
this any of this like this guy that
worked this guy who barely spoke English
that worked back in a you know like a
line cook with him and Dan was like
eating the tomato soup and because he's
like I'm gonna eat he's like I don't
want to get like super fat I mean I
guess I'll just have the soup so he's
like put the soup in a bowl and the guy
just like knocked it out of his hand
is it measured in grams no it's measured
in seconds what do you mean a second
it's like how long do you hold the thing
the lid with the can upside down pouring
salt for like 17 seconds worth of salt
and so he used to tell us like dude
don't eat the [__] and that's how I feel
about everything like um when we sold a
milk Road
to Mike and Kendall these guys are they
come from an affiliate marketing
background and so what they do is they
make websites that are like news or blog
sites that rank at the top of Google and
they're the authoritative example like
they were doing it for
um gold buying gold online and so they
were like should I buy gold or the price
of gold over time or should I buy gold
uh coins or bars and so whatever
question you would ask they wanted to be
the number one result the other guy did
it in for for sports betting so it'd be
like
um you know is it legal to gamble in the
state or like you know what's the best
place what's the best place or what's
the safest place to do X and so there
you go during this time Google so as I
met them and I was like okay
so who else does things like this and
it's like dude have you ever Googled
anything like every top result in Google
is the same model like oh you you're
worried about that uh whatever like that
that thing on your elbow yeah Google
that oh you found Healthline cool yeah
hellfind seems like a great website
right super helpful for you you're
making a medical kind of decision on
whether to worry about this or not off
of Health it's owned by an SEO company
it's like Red Ventures yeah it's like oh
this rolls back up to Red Ventures and
so does this credit card website and so
does this other thing you want to know
what's the best credit card don't Google
it you want to know what's going on with
your health don't Google it because
not only is their model that they're
just gonna write whatever's gonna Rank
and then when they rank they're going to
promote whatever they get paid on as an
affiliate and they'll try to say no no
no we just say that what's the best and
if they happen to be an affiliate they
happen to be an affiliate but we don't
let that affect our editorial rankings
yeah right [__] that's how you make
your money you're going to promote the
things that'll pay you a bunch of money
um and so dude we used to have like a TV
in our office which the person who had
the most page views that day like things
like that so it's like what does that
make the writer's room do oh yeah yeah
get more pages
dirty thing like I don't think there's a
malicious intent it's just a natural
incentive is all I'm saying which is
that if your natural incentives that one
company does not offer you an affiliate
deal and the other one does
you're probably not going to put the one
that doesn't give you the affiliate deal
as the number one best choice you might
put it as number four right and so the
editorial thing has been slightly
smudged with that
um and so you see this with everything
and then you're like Okay cool so who's
writing these articles it must be like
you guys have all these doctors on stuff
or uh not a chance and that's an SEO
specialist and some upwork yeah
you know the
writing our best articles and you know
we pay him 19 per day
I'm just making all these numbers up but
like you get the idea this is like it's
basically what ranks in Google is
somebody who understands how to rank in
Google which is not the same thing as
the person who has the right answer and
once you see how the how the content
gets made once you see how the tomato
soup gets made at Noodles and Company
you uh become very you know suspicious
or skeptical of things which has you
know pros and cons I would say
all right well
sorry everyone so uh what do you got
next topic what else do you want to [__]
on
um okay let's do a quick one and then I
have another one um I put this thing in
here the work smarter not harder hack I
sent that to you you said this okay this
is amazing explain what this is
so uh no you explained well we just need
a life
I sent this to the group chat because I
thought it was hilarious this was really
funny a guy at bar stool basically is a
guy who works at Barstool
um or sorry barcel retweeted this but
it's kind of an ad so there's a a tweet
we will we'll play it in the in the
YouTube video If you see it but like
basically there's a guy who goes out to
like a party and he's just looks like uh
he he he's wearing no shirt he's like in
Miami somewhere it looks like and it
looks like he's live streaming and so he
goes up to this girl she's like no way
50 000 people are watching this oh my
God and then he's like yeah what's up
guys all they want to know what you know
what's the craziest place you've ever
been she's like um um she's like panic
because 50 000 people are watching and
then she's like how are you so famous
yeah and he just like doesn't answer or
something like that and then he just
does it's a montage of a bunch of people
reacting he's like going into the club
and he's like yo what's up y'all we're
at this place and the guy's like hey go
ahead VIP and so basically it's all fake
it's just a fake live stream
uh screen and so it just looks like
you're live it looks like you're on IG
live it'll say live it'll show 50 000
people are watching this the comments
are flooding and you look like you're
some sort of celebrity but it's that's
all the app does it's called parallel
live I think it's a real app by the way
it's real I'm on it right now yeah by
Big Brain it's LLC work harder or sorry
work smarter not harder yeah that's like
everything
I try not to get jealous anymore but I'm
jealous I didn't think of this app to be
honest with you because by the way I did
this when I was younger we did a version
of this that made sense back in the day
where we paid a guy to walk around with
a camera behind us like we were on a
reality show like an on the shoulder
camera and we were like dude I bet you
like
you know we won't need to do anything
tonight we don't need to pay for stuff
we don't need to approach people we
don't need to wait in line watch and uh
it's sure sure enough it played out
completely that way and so I I was sort
of on to this idea you know more than a
day 15 years ago now and uh I think this
is so smart what a great idea dude my
best friend Neville so you can Google
this so Neville Medora so
n-e-d-h-o-r-a so Neville madora one year
during South by Southwest so Neville's
Indian but he's from whatever part of
India he's from he looks Persian so uh
one year he um he uh wore like uh like
these stereotypical things that you see
in the Middle East of where it's like a
white you know like what do they call
that a white gown with like a book oh
yeah yeah with like a head cap thing and
he basically looked he's like I'm gonna
look like a middle eastern Prince like
that's my goal tonight and his other
friend I think it was Noah and a few
other guys wore black suits and he
he said they walked around South they
walked around in the evening on South by
Southwest and he goes we got in
everywhere they thought I was from the
Middle East and I had uh like I was this
king or Prince and I had people coming
up for me up to me constantly and like
uh his friend Noah would like Whispering
a girl's ear like hey this man wants to
speak to you and they like kept up this
[__] going for a while and if you Google
it you'll be able to find it but um dude
this type of these types of pranks are
my are my favorite
what's the play the clip sometimes you
just want to do hood rat [__] with your
friends but I wanted to do Hood right
stuff for my friend
that's what this is this is a app that
lets you do hood rat [__] with your
friends parallel live genius big brains
LLC I went and looked at what other apps
they've made there's one thing called a
relationship one right a relationship
tracker and it's got 17 ratings and two
stars
um you know this is you can almost see
the the um the development of an
entrepreneur go to their App Store and
it's like starts with like productivity
app to-do list
um you know bus tracker to be more
efficient
um oh something that helps you save your
you know your favorite memories with
your family and then it starts to become
like Hot or Not uh fake live stream
simulator you know get laid tonight
exactly
um so you know that's like it's like
eventually you stop selling what you
want people to do and you start selling
what people want to do
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
[Music]
um all right let's do one more thing
what do you got um I had a fun meeting I
want to tell you a little bit about so I
went and met up with uh James Courier
who is an internet OG I know this guy I
like him he runs something called nfx
now which is a big fund like they have
like a billion he's a 1.2 billion under
management or something like that oh I
don't know so it's grown a lot uh back
in the day he started a company called
tickle uh here's another example of you
start by doing what you think you should
do and then you at the end you give
people what they actually want so tickle
started off doing
um cycle like psych quizzes so it'd be
like you know
um I forgot what's that thing called
Briggs Myers and Myers-Briggs or
whatever that's it I think originally
for like which jobs are you built for or
something yeah things like that it was
like trying to like help you figure out
what you should what career you should
do blah blah blah and then the thing
that went viral was what dog breed are
you when you take a quiz it's like
you're a Husky and you're like oh that's
so cute I'm gonna tell all my friends
about this it went super viral and then
they started making more and more silly
quizzes eventually they sell the thing
for for about 100 million dollars to
monster
um or kind of like a good A great win uh
in the early internet days and then they
did a bunch of other things so they've
and they kind of like it it invented a
little bit of the of the uh internet
virality if I remember correctly your
old boss Michael worked with them and I
think like Rick Marini was there too who
Rick Marini now owns what's the gay
dating app uh that went public uh
grinder Rick Marina Rick mourini owns
that yeah well he owns he didn't start
it no he didn't start it but Rick Marini
uh owns or founded the PE firm that
eventually bought grinder and I think
they either took it public or they sold
it to someone and it went public some
something like that but it was like a
pretty good day yeah yeah yeah so these
guys are all about they've been doing
this from the beginning and if I
remember correctly like they invented
little things that we like take for
granted today or things that don't even
work anymore like for example uh uh
enter in your Gmail here and we'll email
all of your friends to ask if they also
want to join along this thing and they
grew that way uh yeah they basically
were like kind of um
they were early to the viral game and so
they bought Mike so Michael Birch who
was my former boss and an investor
um they bought his first social network
Ringo and what Michael the way Michael
described to me was he's like I built
this social networking thing uh it grew
to like 300 000 users which was like
really big at that time and the
internet's like that was like a big
internet thing he's like it was crazy so
much money to run it uh pre-facebook
didn't know what to do with it didn't
know nobody thought social networking
was gonna be like a money making thing
it just seemed like a kind of time waste
he's like so they offered me a couple
million bucks I sold it I worked at
tickle for like nine months or something
like that and then I
um I was like you know I learned a bunch
of things through sitting in an office
with these really smart people and when
my earn out was done or my my
non-compete was done I went and I was
like now I know how to do this right and
he built bibo which got a million
members in nine days using everything he
had learned during that period and ended
up selling for 850 million dollars and
so
um yeah they kind of were all this
cluster of people that were doing the
early address book Imports and how to
measure if I reality with the K factor
that sort of thing
um
so I go meet with James and uh what was
the premise of the meeting
so the premise of the meeting was just
catch up so he knew that I sold the milk
Road he was like you know what do you
think about doing next and I was like
I'm not sure let's uh let's chat so he
invites me down to Palo Alto and so it
could have been a zoom but
I was like no no Sean's leaving the
house today uh let's go meet belly to
belly here and and I think it's it's
going to be worth it totally was totally
was worth it so
I go down there
um first thing I noticed was like
his office is right on like whatever
like University Ave or whatever that is
in Palo Alto where it's like everything
is there it's like right in the middle
so
I just kind of noted that observation I
was like oh that's interesting that he
like made that choice could have been
somewhere else bde that's that's big
dick energy second thing was
um there wasn't really anybody else in
the office but like he was there and uh
I think other people may be working
remote so we sit down we start chatting
and um I wanted to give you some of my
notes from from this thing so the first
thing is
um
he's uh have you ever met him before
yeah he's like he's he's really nice and
can have a conversation but he's like a
quirky uh not quite I wouldn't use the
word eccentric but he's just like uh uh
he loves this network density stuff and
it's like [__] sharing stuff I don't
know I mean he's very academic almost
about it he uh yeah personality wise
he's got a great Vibe like he's very
lighthearted uh and yeah himself too
seriously like you know I even wrote
this I emailed him afterwards which is a
little life hack by the way I emailed
him afterwards I was like here's my
notes from the meeting people don't
usually do that they don't hey they
don't even take notes but like if they
do they keep it to themselves but if you
actually send the person the notes they
really appreciate it and it's almost
like it's a double meeting
so he sent me like a revision of one
thing so here's my um can I read you my
takeaways from from the meeting I go
here's here's my my notes five big
takeaways I like your lifestyle so I
learned something that's a great
compliment too by the way yeah I go I
like the way you I like your lifestyle I
like how you use your Financial Freedom
so he said he spent four months a year
with his kids
um so it's like just four months out of
the year he's with his kids they travel
they do his stuff and he's like dude
that's the max your kids will want to be
around you he's like I have teenage kids
like that is I'm pushing the boundary of
like how much I can max four months in
one turn like summertime per year yeah
no no like spread out okay probably a
couple in the summer and then whatever
the rest uh he's writing a TV show for
fun right now and I was like like that
want to do things like that I think
that's dope that you have a life that
lets you do that noted uh because I'm uh
he's 55 I think and I'm 35 and so you
know I'm basically looking at like I'm
always hunting for blueprints like who's
got a gold lifestyle and not their whole
blueprint but like part of their where I
want to cherry pick it's like Costco I
want to go around and Sample different
people and then be like Oh I like that I
like the way that Sam has his Ranch and
how he does things and his like your
home gym for example I went to your
place Austin your home gym was awesome
and then I came home and I was like Sam
what'd you use for the floor what'd you
buy for this how do you get the leaves
out what do you do this and you gave me
the thing and I recreated that and you
know with a 10 change in my own how's it
going is it awesome oh dude it's amazing
yeah and so like that's that was what I
stole from you and then did you get the
cordless leaf blower the leaf Blower's
dope it's also a great party trick by
the way people are just like uh if
people people love it uh but it's super
effective it's way way easier than
sweeping so
uh so anyways I was like I like your
lifestyle for these reasons I I told him
a bunch of stuff um then I go then I go
the second good thing he told me he goes
I think I could say this let me say let
me try to say this without causing any
uh a ruffled any feathers here so he's
like where do you he's like where do you
want to land in the uh the status game
so he's like okay so he draws this like
line on the board he goes
on one side of the spectrum you have
like let's say garyvee
or like 500 startups or like he's like
you know think about like people who go
for a like a mass market like Tony
Robbins they try to reach like a mass
Market type of individual with their
content and
um and then that becomes Their audience
that becomes their deal flow so you know
if if a really popular person sends me
like oh here's a startup I got pitched
I'm like he's like I kind of know where
that's gonna be in the quality filter
versus if sequoia or Benchmark sends me
a deal like I know where that is and the
quality filter that's on the other end
of the spectrum they have a much more
Niche audience they're only creating
like nfx he creates really Niche content
that's for like an A plus founder who's
trying to build a billion dollar company
using network effects
you're referring to nfx the blog or nfx
they're customer base or both like the
blog is to attract a certain type of
founder he doesn't need a million hits
on a video he needs like the right
hundred people to read the thing right
um so that they think about nfx and they
learn from and so
um he's like we're on this you're you're
making content but who's your customer
are you more like McDonald's or you know
we're like a say a Michelin star
restaurant they're like McDonald's you
know we're not going to get the volume
that they get but they're not going to
get the quality of clientele we get you
know so we're he's like today MFM he's
like is in he's in the middle here he's
like and my advice to you is don't slide
down that way he's like because today I
like you guys and I tell people to
listen to you guys because
you're like you keep it real when it
comes to entrepreneurship like hey you
guys are real entrepreneurs you've done
it before B you just tell it like it is
see you don't talk about the most like
complex subjects you like simple
businesses and and you know more
achievable business models for most
people but you're not yelling at them to
hustle harder you're not just hustle
porn that's just saying like bro you
need to grind and like you need to do
whatever and then motivational because
we try to be motivational and we're not
promoting
paths that are like um
you know drop shipping and like you know
flipping things on eBay or whatever like
you know there's a a business class
there where neither nor are we saying
like Enterprise SAS isn't like the main
thing we talk about either so it's like
yeah we're somewhere in the middle he's
like I think you should stay in the
middle because it'll be tempting to
slide there to get more views
but I don't think that's what you're
going to want in the end because that
will be the network you create those
will be the deals you get those will be
the people who like you those will be
the people you meet and so you will your
your content will Define which network
you're a part of today you're here you
can kind of go either way
um you should either stay there move up
Market but like he's like my my advice
to you is don't don't slide down Market
there so I thought that was interesting
nobody really talked about that and
there's also like
um you know I hadn't gone through this
exercise recently where it was like
defining kind of like your your brand
like who do you talk to who's your
customer and who who do you who do you
like to create content for and initially
the thing I thought about was like
usually it's like oh you know I'm all
about entrepreneurship I'm all about
starting your own business and that's
what I did and that's what I like but
there's many different flavors of that
there's like Tech startups like more
like YC there's stuff like starting an
agency there's different stuff in
between and then there's some people who
are like they cater to a market of
people that are like kind of like
entrepreneurs only so it's like quit
your nine to five job don't be a slave
to the cubicle get out there and Be Your
Own Boss type of messaging and I'm like
I don't feel like the people who listen
to us are
mostly in that category like
I think the people who talk to often are
like second time Founders they're people
who are they own small businesses or
they they're actually planning to take
shots and they're not like they already
have made the decision of like I'm not
gonna like struggle in this nine to five
I don't you know I don't think it's a
Dairy Queen worker that's our main like
kind of person who listens so it was
just like interesting to hear that
um okay here's the last thing that I
think is two two last things uh one
partnership advice so him and his buddy
Stan have been partners for I think like
20 years now yeah forever and I had
talked to Stan before I met James and I
asked him I go hey I want to have a
Business Partnership that's like yours
like a business marriage not just a
partnership like your thing is like
multi-decades there's no end in sight
and it's been great and you guys have
had multiple successes with the same
people what's the secret
and normally when you ask somebody this
like the odds of them actually saying
something insightful are very very low
but you can tell like how good they are
that off the cuff he's like there's four
things you need to know oh my God
he tells you the four things and I'm
like what are these four things so
here's what he told me he goes
he goes most relationships are
um both sides are focused on what
they're getting out of it he goes you're
he goes the first thing if you want this
to work is you make it a giving contest
like a giving contest he goes yeah he
goes when we sold our first company
James owned 90 of it or something like
that 80 90 and he owned stand on like 10
or 20
and right before the deal closed
um James like evened up the the thing
and he was like what uh he's like no no
you don't need to do that because James
had had I think some financial success
right before that or something and so
he's like no that's not right and James
was like no this is this is right
and he's like in a moment where
everybody would have been selfish he had
every right to just keep the deal
exactly as is I'm I'm more of a gift
basket type of guy
um and I've I've kind of done it both
ways it's not about like you don't have
to just make everything 50 50. I don't
think that's the right answer but I
think making sure everybody's taken care
of is an important thing when we sold
bibo the first time
um or when I saw people to Twitch I own
double the equity that my co-founder uh
furcon owned and so on paper I should
have got double what he got
and as we're getting close to the deal I
told him I said hey uh we're gonna get
the same like whatever that total pool
is we're just gonna split that 50 50 of
what we get out of between me and you
because you know that's what felt right
to me and uh you know I was like this is
I think this is what is this before
furcon had was this before app app love
and sold
uh no that's old but then actually so
wow and so for those who don't know
Sean's partner helped found App 11 which
varies in market cap between 20 40 and
50 billion dollars it's like a huge
thing and so you still I mean he had a
that was that's probably a home run for
him financially the the app 11. yeah
yeah I mean the app level thing is way
bigger for him than than our deal was
um and we knew like he was going to be
wealthy from that uh so you know it
wasn't I I don't know like I just felt
felt it was the right thing to do and
what I it was actually it wasn't like
dude I'm gonna make it so that we're
even that's that's not really the
mentality it was
I the original deal was not fair and so
I just wanted to correct it
um like when he joined the company he
had like point five percent of equity or
something like that and so I had already
upped him once Upton twice up to I'd
been upping him without him asking
anyways just because I was like this
first deal was wrong so now I just try
to cut the right deal up front so you
don't have to do that anymore
um but like the point is like you try to
do what what is actually right so
anyways so that was the first lesson
from Stan was like he's like I never
feel like uh he's like I basically feel
like we are both trying to give more and
it's not about Equity only like it's
like effort like he's gonna do something
I want to do more
um he's gonna you know try to like you
know make some sacrifice I want to
sacrifice the same amount or more let's
turn it into a giving contest that was
lesson one he goes lesson two
when you disagree or you fight
which is going to happen a lot and you
have to decide which way to go do we go
my way or do we go your way don't use
logic use the sleep test so he's like I
ask who cares who is more emotionally
invested in this in this decision
because
if I'm if we go with my way but you were
more emotionally invested you're not
gonna be able to sleep at night and if I
turn out to be wrong it's going to
really hurt you if I'm a little less
emotionally invested in this let's go
your way and we agree that we'll just
you know we'll pivot if we need to
um you know later and he's like when
it's really like just a deadlock that's
how we resolve the deadlock is who's not
gonna be able to sleep at night yeah
about this thing and when you have that
attitude uh you know both sides end up
trying to compromise versus trying to
get their way
um three he goes I think in 20-year
increments so
if I'm going to work with this person
for 20 years what decision would I make
today that's going to be the best in a
20-year time Spirit versus how most
people operate is they just make a
decision today about what's good today
and then the future consequences may not
be that good but they're thinking short
term whereas if if we plan for this to
be long term we're going to make
different decisions today to set
ourselves up for long-term success
um so that's number three he goes number
four
um
uh the last thing I go I go hey I asked
him I go I go okay that's the
partnership Stan why why are you great
why is Zuck recruiting her because he
ended up getting recruited by Mark
Zuckerberg to go run I know this guy
Facebook messenger and didn't you go and
actually do that he went and did it and
he had and they've been trying to get
recruited for like years like you know
seven to ten years it finally said yes
and I go
um I I asked him two questions I go uh
what makes you great and what makes that
great he goes
because I'm not that talented but here's
my thing I'm not because I don't have
the same bias as most people I don't
have to be right I go what do you mean
he goes
when I look at data
everybody else I find they look at data
and they just they have a story in their
head they want to be true then they look
at data and try to find will they keep
searching through data until they find
something that supports their story it
goes I look at data and I ask a simple
question what story is this telling me
and he goes he goes I just keep doing
that and I just make better decisions
because I do that because that's my
approach to to how I actually read data
that's why I can have more business
success than what about Zuck and on the
Zuck side he I go like what makes that
great he said you know he didn't want to
say the obvious things here he's
brilliant hard-working like that would
be a pretty blah answer again that's how
you know the quality of the person they
just skip over the blah answer they give
you what you want they give you a little
candy so here's the candy he goes
I was sitting with Zuck when he decided
to buy WhatsApp and everybody said it
was way too expensive they bought it for
19 billion dollars and WhatsApp wasn't
producing any Revenue
what's that worth now you think I don't
even know hard to say uh I don't know a
lot more though I think more yeah
um like the Instagram one definitely
they bought it from 1 billion is
probably worth 100 now
um what's that probably double that
sorry but what's that's probably also
100 billion dollar franchise so he was
trying to decide to do it and he goes
you know what's great about you mark
you're lucky you're smart enough to know
that you got lucky once and you found
lightning in a bottle with this when
social networking was going to be a
thing
but you're smart enough to know when
somebody else got lucky too and he goes
uh he goes you are smart enough to know
that this Mo this messaging thing was
like this was the big winner of this era
and these guys got it and you need to
pay whatever effing price you have to
pay to get it because there's only going
to be one the way that there was
Facebook like there was only gonna be
one big winner right and you you know
that you don't think you're so genius
that you're just gonna out-compete
everybody and beat everybody at
everything like you're you can recognize
when somebody else got lucky too and uh
and I thought that was just like a fun
answer for her for her did he say that
he liked did he like working with Zuck
uh you know he's not gonna tell me if he
hated it and he but you know the action
speak louder he's been there for quite a
while I think he's I think he just left
this year and so I think he was there
for like seven years or something so how
did this guy run nfx Labs while working
at Facebook he didn't he just worked at
Facebook and he came as an advisor and
then James was like again no problem go
do that take the big fat check I'll run
on FX you keep your partnership
dude how much does a person like that
make like if you're the head of a
Facebook person uh a Facebook business
are you making over 10 million a year I
have no idea yeah yeah for sure you
think so for sure wow I have no idea I
say for sure like I know I don't
actually know what he was making but I
would be stunned if it was less than 10
million a year I think it's probably
closer to 20 million a year
that's so much money there are people at
these companies that make 40 50 billion
dollars per year uh like because they
had stock grants early on and they just
stayed there no no no not the early on
type person like they'll get a package
in 2019 that at the 2019 prices is going
to pay them 20 to 40 million dollars a
year they're usually like the top AI guy
because they're like look this if this
top AI guy leaves and goes to another
company not only do we lose this Talent
that's kind of Irreplaceable but then
Google gets them and then you know now
they have a problem so like Google has
published some of these numbers about
guys were making like you know 30 40
million dollars a year I want to have a
I don't know if this has to be anonymous
or what but I want to have a
conversation with one of these kind of
OG guys who saw the Twitter Facebook's
uh like some of these companies get
created Google like get created because
you know they're around they're and
they're probably only 50 or 60 years old
you know the people who saw Google like
who are a little bit older when Google
was getting started I want to ask them
all stories about that and just what's
it like being around some of these
people and what are some of the stories
around when it was getting going like
you hear these crazy stories about like
I think we had I think we had someone on
here talk about eBay and they're like I
joined eBay when we were 50 people and
they were just explaining what like the
day-to-day office life was when you're
adding 50 employees a month or 50
employees a week when you're only at 50
people and uh anyway I because this type
of stuff doesn't it truly exist anymore
because the map
the playbook for for a fast Growth
Company is kind of it's not entirely
made and there's still companies like
uber that are recreating it as they go
but like there's a story there and you
have a history but if you're Google
you're a little bit of a Pioneer and
you're like I don't know man how do we
how do we add bodies to this problem I
don't know but anyway I want to hear I
want to get some OG's on to tell those
stories yeah
that yeah that would be awesome
um I've heard I've been lucky to hear a
couple like uh the guy who was the my
boss at twitch essentially was uh
semi-early at Google so he would be like
you know Larry says this he's talking
about Larry Page like from Google and so
like he didn't do it often but like he
would say these little things that I
would like ask him a million questions
about it dude so when my wife my wife
Sarah worked at Facebook from 2000 and I
feel like forget exactly maybe 13 to 16.
and during that time Facebook I think
she was she joined at like 5 000 and
then when she left there at like 50 000
something crazy and during that time
Zuck would do these meetings every
Friday in like an auditorium or in a
cafeteria on Facebook's campus and any
employee can could show up and just ask
him a question and they would also
stream them and every once in a while I
would like look over her computer and
watch her streaming these uh conferences
and there'd be like 50 or 100 people in
the cafeteria asking questions to Zuck
and I'm like Sarah you are crazy you
should be in that cafeteria every single
Friday like this is like being around
like John Rockefeller or like Teddy
Roosevelt or JFK like this is like a
pretty big deal and if you just ask an
interesting question every Friday maybe
eventually he'll say something like
Sarah it's nice to see you again you
know like why don't you just come talk
to me afterwards and we could help maybe
you could work on that price like fan
fiction yeah he'll still sleep with you
and then
I'm like creating this story in my head
I'm like what could potentially happen
and uh it never happened to each other
in the elevator and he says yeah
right you have like a meat cute in the
cafeteria and he like says like nice
shoes and like you already know you're
like boyfriend I want to hang out with
who knows and maybe you're posting a
bunch of pictures of me and I just so
happen to like play Bobby that's him I
don't know I haven't thought this too
already but like
like I had this whole Playbook
and she didn't do any of it and instead
we just had a traditional fall in love
marriage and all that boring she's like
a yoga class during the All Hands yeah
we could have had a throuple with Zuck
but no
well dude this is this is one of the
other things that James was talking
about actually like to kind of actually
relate to that he goes um
I asked him I was like so
um I asked him about his office member I
told you I was like I noted that he was
here I was like why do you have the
why'd you get in office right here he's
like
I mean it's a no-brainer if he goes uh
he goes I made one mistake when we sold
tickle I drew a diagram he goes he drew
a circle
he goes on the diagram guy I like this
oh dude if you if I'm gonna meet you in
person we're gonna be on the Whiteboard
like you know that's what's gonna happen
yeah it's going down yeah it's going
down you know I'm a lady in the streets
and a freak on the Whiteboard and
um and so he's he draws a circle he's
like yeah they'll say that he's like the
white hot Center of Silicon Valley was
like let's say Sequoia Benchmark these
you know these people these Founders at
that time Facebook was just getting
started Facebook was like the hot Center
of like where all the action was
happening Google it goes and then like
you know one ring out from that you know
we were kind of like adjacent like we
knew a lot of those people like I helped
you know you know I advise some people
to take jobs there you know I had a job
offer there he's like I didn't take it
because I've maybe had a little too much
ego I thought I was an entrepreneur
probably should have just joined
Facebook it would have been great
um he's like yeah but we were like one
one hop away we were like one one ring
away in this like Circle
it goes
what we should have done is realize that
Silicon Valley is a network and in a
network like all the value like a lot of
the value concentrates at the core like
the closer you are to the center of the
network the more value you get
physically in many cases as well
literally physically which is like he's
like he's like uh he's like um he's like
the further you go out the the more
you're on your own Island he goes we
decided to go start our own thing our
own lab self-funded doing our own
startups with new people and like you
know doing our own thing and it felt so
entrepreneurial to go out on our own
terms and build our own Island he goes I
he goes I could see you making this
mistake too because I wish somebody had
explained this to me at the time he goes
and you see this all the time you know
um he goes I can't believe people are
moving out of the tech people are moving
out of the Bay Area to go live in Austin
or you know Florida or these places uh
You're Gonna Save 13 on your taxes but
make 10 times less money like you know
that's the trade that they're making
they just don't really buy that and he
goes
um when we did this because when we
moved out here you know when we decided
to go off and kind of do our own thing
not physical it's not geographically but
just like in a philosophically all of a
sudden he goes I had a meeting with a
meeting schedule with the Uber Founders
because you know they were in our
Network and our friend was like you
should meet with the Uber guys Travis is
doing something cool and um had the
meeting scheduled but I was so focused
oh I'm doing my thing here and I got
busy and I had to I just canceled the
meeting didn't take the meeting
um missed Uber would have would have
definitely invested in it at that time
just because in the network as our
friends put a small check in you know no
big deal but I was so focused on
building my own little island I I
stopped paying into the network it goes
you know similarly I could have took a
job at Facebook at that time been like
you know one of the earliest people at
Facebook I kind of knew Facebook was
going to be a big deal
um but again had my own thoughts about
what I wanted to do so I went the other
way and made things harder for myself
rather than easier he goes you could see
what like the value of the network he
goes when Facebook started getting
popular Facebook started in in Boston
and he goes Zuck was smart and Peter
Thiel told him the right thing which is
get your ass to you know get your ass to
Silicon Valley as fast as possible
because the startup that builds this in
Silicon Valley is gonna have a better
shot better High expected value than one
that tries to do this on their own in a
new Talent Network you know at a new
funding Network outside of Silicon
Valley and um and I was asking about YC
I go well didn't kind of YC do their own
thing he goes no I have the opposite
view of IC YC is fully a network and he
goes Paul Graham did the first one in
Boston and immediately moved to Silicon
Valley because he had figured out oh
[__] this is the blueprint for for
investing in early stage startups that's
going to work
whoever does this in Silicon Valley is
going to be the winner and he goes guess
what they moved to Silicon Valley right
away as soon as their first batch was
done Paul has two little kids they just
forget drop everything pick up and move
like he's like you know it wasn't
convenient for them he's like I know the
architect that was building their house
and you know they had to get there
quickly and they just rushed it moved in
start their second batch in Silicon
Valley because they look at all the
other accelerators that copied their
exact blueprint the all the you know
Tech Stars is the one in Boulder every
other city and you know they've had like
a couple unicorns Paul you know has had
100 and it's like you know the
difference is like a you know more than
a 10x difference in outcome just by
being in the center of the network and
he goes
um and I saw it so I was thinking about
that I was like you know there's a
physical location part of that
then there's like staying in touch with
people so like me doing that meeting
with James was great because like yeah
this guy's in my network but I was just
sitting in the burbs over here you know
doing my own thing here creating my own
content do you not feel like a Silicon
Valley guy because you're dude I haven't
been going to anything like I don't meet
with anybody I don't go to anything it's
like dumb and then this brought my
awareness to like wow I'm silly for not
taking advantage of the network that I
the hard Network that I've built over
you know 10 12 years
um that's crazy that I'm not taking
advantage of that
um and then so I asked him I was like
you know what do you think uh uh I was
like how do you actually take advantage
of the network besides physically being
there okay I believe the physical thing
and I've always said this like proximity
Is Power the closer you can be to the
people you like and the people you want
to be like and the people you want to be
around like literally physically the
closer you could be the better and I go
why does that work and he goes
he goes what you should do is that
you want to build something that brings
value not only to you but also to those
people around you also you want to be
like an API so like you know when a when
Twitter is a product they create an API
that lets other people like read the
Twitter stream write create apps that
help Twitter like this makes Twitter
stronger it makes Twitter stronger he's
like you want to be like an API you want
to tell you want to tell people how they
can plug into you where can they get
help from you how can they give help to
you like uh if we know that Andrew
Wilkinson buys internet companies then
when we see it internet company we talk
to some guy who's like yeah I'm thinking
about selling we'll make that
introduction because Andrew has an open
API he has made it clear how somebody
can interface with him how somebody can
help him and how he can help other
people you know he he's made it clear
for those Founders hey if you want to
exit I'll I'll buy you out and so he's
like that's why Silicon Valley is great
because
you can invest in other people's stuff
you can join them you can partner with
them you can work for them you can send
them Talent you can do a podcast
exchange you can share ideas about
growth with each other you can share
knowledge about a term sheet which is
like that's why Silicon Valley works is
because the network is super dense and
people share a ton within that and so
you get all these extra benefits that
you don't really plan for that are sort
of serendipitous when you're in there
and I I thought like this is all obvious
like I kind of nodded my head but it
brought my awareness too it's not that
obvious a lot of people don't take
advantage of this stuff and even me who
still who knows this stuff and still
lives in silica Valley I wasn't maxing
that out and I'm gonna make a you know a
a sort of like turn that knob a little
bit and do that better
if I could
I only live Where I Live Now for family
reasons but if my family were willing to
live in California I would be in Palo
Alto not San Francisco actually but pal
I would be down the peninsula in a
heartbeat totally 100 I would be there
in a heartbeat I think it's the greatest
and people say like well it doesn't
matter anymore I'm like well maybe like
currently it doesn't matter that much
but things that maybe in the six or 12
months it's going to be happening but I
actually think it has kind of happening
still a little bit but uh I think New
York and and and Silicon Valley are a
little bit on uh even actually now
whereas for years they weren't but still
Silicon Valley I think has a much better
uh you have a much better existence
living there but I would be there in a
heartbeat if I could if it were if I was
a single guy I would be there tomorrow
right
um cool all right I think we went a
little over but that's it that's it
that's the pod
[Music]